[تصفيق]
مع انتهاء مراسم الاحتفال الملكي في
المملكه المتحده ينتظر البريطانيون يوم
غداء التتويج حيث سيكون الطبق الذي اختاره
الملك تشارلز الثالث في ابريل الماضي سيد
المائده
طبق فرنسي يزين حفله يدعى الكيش وصفه شهيه
من المعجنات الخفيفه مكونه من السبانخ
والفول والترخون وبعض الفاصولياء العريضه
معه سيحاول حظ الناس على طعام صحي يغير من
خلاله عادات اكلهم ويحث فيه على المنتجات
العضويه طبق يعبر عن شخصيه تشارلز نفسه
بسيط بتفضيلاته وصحي بمكوناته ومرن
باختياراته المهم ان يقتنع بالامر وان كان
باريسيا
وعن هذا الاختيار فيرجعه خبراء التغذيه
الى اهتمامه بالطبيعه منذ ان كان طفلا
وشابا الى ان اصبح ملكا تؤرقه التغيرات
المناخيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات